how do Australians process it who's your  enemy uh we've got the same problem  we've had a recent Federal Election  where you know Miami was the other guy  politically no hang on it doesn't matter  if you're in Australia it doesn't matter  what gender you are what pronoun you put  in front of your name what state you  come from and the color of your skin  whether you're wealthy or Rich actually  you're firstly an Australian and you've  got a joint interest in keeping the  place if you're like safe for democracy  where there's Prosperity there's  opportunity for your kids where you're  not going to be hauled off in the middle  of the night there's no fellow  Australian serious Australian that wants  to do that to you I mean obviously I  think they're direct parallels here with  your Society but there are people who  are massing massive military capacity  around the world who would do anything  to take those things from you or they  don't care about your internal Wars